this is the nexus one this is the first
phone released directly by google
available to the public through google's
website it's been a few years in the
making it's been contracted out by HTC
and it's a beautiful piece of hardware
it's got a 5 megapixel camera has
android obviously in addition to that it
has a micro SD card so it's good up to
32 gigabytes and it is available through
pretty much any carrier that has a GSM
now it's five hundred and twenty nine
dollars and additionally if you do want
to stick with the carrier and get a
little bit of a price break you can
spend one hundred and seventy nine
dollars a tmobile with a two-year
contract but pretty much this is a big
big deal for google and it's a big deal
for cell phones they're going
head-to-head against apple with a
beautiful touchscreen it's got haptic
feedback it has voice search and in
addition it has voice controls so if you
if you clock into any SMS or any other
text function you can talk directly and
it will literally translate everything
you're saying so you can search the
phone you can converse with your friends
and that's a big big big deal you cannot
do that on the iphone or any other
smartphone currently so it is called the
nexus one which actually means that
they're probably going to release the
nexus 2 maybe sometime in the next year
maybe not who knows
you